another big honor for local teacher  juliana ertabay today the las vegas city  council honored the national teacher of  the year  as citizen of the year urtube teaches  special education over at booker  elementary  i just want to say thank you i mean this  is  beyond what a teacher could imagine i'm  so excited to represent teachers  not just in our great state but across  the country  and lift our voices there are so many  amazing classroom teachers  in not just the clark county but across  the state  she's quite a teacher there as teacher  of the year erta bay will spend the next  year helping inspire future educators  and students